what are we doing today we are getting
the best 4k
tv
that is absolutely correct we recently
moved and today we have got ourselves an
lg g1 evo tv the best 4k tv that is
around um i've looked into oled tvs for
a long time i have owned one in the past
but this is the real deal we want
something that's high quality it's going
to last and that is why we are getting
one of these so there's multiple reasons
why this is the best 4k tv now the first
one is obvious and that is the fact that
it is oled so we've had qled tvs before
obviously lcds we still have an lcd
display it's the only one we kept moving
here we try to get rid of as much stuff
as possible and i was asking noah if he
remembered anything from that tv and
what stood out and what did you tell me
noah
it turns off a tiny bit of the
screen that is pitch black like if you
want something to be black it turns
pitch yep that's absolutely true what
did you mention this part was really
cool we didn't really talk about this
ahead of time you mentioned your watch
everything around it
is bright but the parts that needs to be
black are pitch black yeah that's
absolutely true so noah has an apple
watch ase if you guys watched the video
last year and i was shocked that he you
know figured that out it is an oled
display so everything's really dark so
yes you're absolutely right this thing
is an oled same exact technology as your
watch and it makes it look amazing now
what else do you remember from our last
oled tv that one at night we're watching
a movie yeah and the screen was really
bright the one we had was a six series
this one right here is i think 11 now
it's so this is the brightest oled panel
that is out there so that one was
amazing for hdr movies when we were
watching end game the fight scenes the
lightning it looked amazing this is even
brighter and that was one downside
actually of oled tvs in the past and
that's one reason we had a q-led before
but then the hdr did not look anywhere
near as good as oled and this guy gets
much brighter all right guys let's get
this thing lowered down and emily what
else are we going to be doing with this
tv
xbox that is absolutely right that's why
we have the series x over there what
games are we going to play emily
directly rocket league yes so that's
another awesome thing about this tv is
four hdmi 2.1 inputs for 4k
120 hertz high refresh rate along with
that dolby vision that supports dolby
vision hdr at 4k 120 and dolby vision in
general which is amazing and then also
atmos sound for the built-in speakers i
hear they are very impressive and with
that it has the a9 gen 4 ai processor
now what most people don't know it's not
only the panel that matters it's the
processing for the hdr that makes it
look a lot better than other third-party
options and with that of course we have
this wall mount now this tv is designed
to be mounted on the wall it's the
gallery design that makes it super thin
from the top all the way to the bottom
so there's no protrusions is that the
remote
let's get the remote out of course lg
has their web os and this thing also
supports hands-free so it'll actually
listen to you for commands and then i
think one of the biggest deals with this
tv is the five-year warranty so people
have talked about burning issues
that's always been a concern
well lg has done such a great job that
now they're giving you a five-year
warranty not a one year or two year that
there is not going to be any burden
there's not going to be any issues and
if something does happen then you'll be
covered and the crazy thing is that even
though lg made this tv better in every
single way they lower the price by 500
bucks compared to last year's model and
that is the next reason why it's the
best 4k tv so if you guys want to check
out more info i will link the page down
below to buy dig that is working with us
on this video so thank you lg thank you
bye day go ahead and check him out and
we are going to go ahead and get this tv
set up so it's been a bit since we set
up the g1 and i want to give you guys my
experience both some things that
surprised me some things that are very
unique to the g1 along with a few
downsides now we set this up in this
little cubby above our fireplace
standard for older homes now i cannot
wait in order to remodel this spring
make a nice modern fireplace and put the
g1 flush on the wall so that is what the
g1 is designed to be a flush mounted
slim tv that looks amazing on your wall
and it doesn't stick out like an ugly
thick box on there with that there are
no legs included in the box you can't
buy them separately but it does come
with a wall mount that is flush so you
can still mount it to you know a tv
stand if you want to do that like what i
did but as far as setup this was the
easiest one i've ever done i did
everything with my phone it was super
quick and then once we got it set up man
this thing looked amazing i did some
tests side by side with my lcd that i
had there that fit in
and you just cannot compare it at all
obviously oled the black levels are
amazing but the hdr the difference is
shocking even sdr it is just crazy i'll
get into that in a sec now hooking up
the xbox everything worked out of the
box perfectly supported 4k 120 supported
hdr dolby vision i went and i toggled
120 hertz and we were playing rocket
league at 120 and it looked amazing
super smooth we've had the series x for
almost a year now this first time we
were able to play at 120 hertz my kids
love it and it looks great to be able to
maximize my console with this tv now i
also played forza and that was with hdr
and wow it looks phenomenal especially
when you're going through trees you have
you know the sun coming through you have
the dark contrast that looks great if
you have the sun in the sky
my camera can't even capture it i had to
turn the exposure way down in order to
not blow out as much stuff so i wish i
could show you guys what it looks like
in person but just the highlights in the
hdr it takes the image to a whole
another level now what's really cool is
that the tv will notice that your gaming
automatically put it into gaming mode
and that brings you down to 5.5
milliseconds uh that is like no lag at
all that's a big reason why people will
buy an lg oled because it is just such a
great experience so if you have a newer
console or you're going to plan to get
one in the future this really
future-proofs your setup especially with
those four hdmi ports they're all hdmi
2.1 not just like one port or two all of
them support it which is awesome now
moving on to videos and movies man it is
better than i expected i had the series
six that was a little bit too large for
this setup but this takes it up to
another level colors look astonishing
once again i wish i could show you
exactly what it looked like because i
can't it looks way better in real life
colors are amazing contrast is amazing
black levels are perfect if you're
watching like the skies anything with
pure blacks that you're watching at
night you have black bars on movies that
is pure black it's not great like my
previous tvs it's amazing you do not
have any blooming or anything like that
and it just i don't know what else to
say you have the specular highlights for
the hdr so so bright much brighter than
before just a big noticeable difference
between uh the previous setup and
anything else like oled in the past sure
that could get bright but just how
bright the highlights that pop in hdr
and how dark the contrast is
you can't compare it and i also
appreciated the filmmaker mode you
literally toggle that it gets rid of any
motion smoothing or anything else you
don't have to go dig through menus like
you had in the past and it just makes
the image look like it should be 24
frames per second and with that there is
no jutter when it plays that it
processes that so you don't get that
stuttering effect that you can with
other tvs if you have a fast pan to 24
fps so movies look phenomenal now on top
of that if you're somebody that wants to
use one of these as their display for
the computer
man it's a great option a lot of people
are doing that now you don't have to
spend 20 30 000 for an hdr editing
monitor or even 6k like i did with the
pro display xdr um this screen gives you
super accurate colors 10-bit support hdr
support for grading so it's a really
really cost effective way to use that if
you're somebody that works with photos
and video
and with that one concern was burn in
and like i mentioned at the start of the
video as far as these new evo panels
they use less power to reach the same
brightness so burning is much less of an
issue it wasn't that bad of an issue
before but now it is so good the lg is
giving you five years warranty not a
standard one year warranty like other
tvs have five years so you can have
confidence that you're not going to have
any issues so if you want to use that as
commuter monitor you definitely can this
tv has atsc 3.0 or next gen tv which is
basically like back in the old days we
just turn on your tv and you get a bunch
of free channels but it is next level
and this is one of the few tvs that have
this so you can actually have 4k over
the air hdr over the over the air up to
120 over the air you can have atmos
sound so that's another thing that in
future tvs some of them are going to
have is going to take a while to go down
to lower price tvs
but if you buy one of these you are
future-proofed and you have access to a
bunch of channels but with really high
quality i currently can't use a sound
bar i'm going to wait until i have
everything set up and maybe i'll do a
home theater system or a sound bar but
compared to my last lg tv which had
amazing speakers for tv this took it up
another level and i don't know how
they're doing it with such a small slim
tv i think that it's up to 60 watts or
so of power and it got way louder than i
expected it also sounded better better
than i expected and i'm used to having
to go up to like 100 and want more
volume out of built-in speakers if you
have to use them like i was but here i
didn't have to do that i could actually
turn it down and have more overhead for
you know videos or movies that might be
a little bit quieter to have that access
so overall i am even more impressed than
i thought it would be this is the size
that i wanted the setup that i wanted
and it takes my previous oled experience
to a whole another level and of course
it is future proof with the hardware
with the inputs
and has a really nice warranty as well
so if you're looking for something that
you know is going to last a long time
you'll have all the inputs that you need
has really great hdr great brightness
especially for an oled
this is the one that you want to get
very low reflectivity even in bright
rooms it performs phenomenally i would
go and check it out i have the link down
to buy dig down below so thank you bye
dig thank you to lg and you guys can
check that out go ahead and click that
circle above to subscribe if you guys
want to see more videos check out one of
those great videos right over there this
max and i will catch you in the next
video
[Music]